con lleva a sus 88 años rey ccoo llamada
es una cara conocida aquí piden ayuda a
los supervivientes de hiroshima
sin esta asociación nuestra historia no
se transmitiría ellos no vivieron la
catástrofe pero están profundamente
implicados esta asociación está decidida
que el mundo no olvide la destrucción de
hiroshima llamada tenía 11 años el 6 de
agosto de 1945 su escuela estaba a 2,5
km del epicentro había un avión y un
destello y luego nada un árbol de cayó
encima pero sobrevivió y encontró a su
familia
evita vamos mirar las caras de los
muertos pero dos días después del ataque
alguien llamó a mi hermana así que nos
dimos la vuelta y vimos la cara de
alguien muy quemada ni siquiera
podríamos distinguir los ojos y la boca
estábamos tan asustadas que corrimos
unas 140.000 personas murieron en el
ataque y durante los meses siguientes
los supervivientes tienen todos más de
80 años esta asociación recibe 12.000
solicitudes de ayuda a cada que coincida
cada toca la mayoría de los
supervivientes viven solos son solteros
o no han tenido hijos
para la transmisión de enfermedades
después de la guerra de los hibakusha
fueron condenados al ostracismo por
haber estado expuestos a la radiación
ocultaron sus cicatrices y algunos nunca
explicaron por lo que habían pasado
llamadas se siente afortunada de no
tener ninguna cicatriz viaja por el
mundo para compartir su experiencia pero
ella y otros hibakusha dicen que sus
voces no son escuchadas igual que este
monumento a las víctimas se les pasa por
alto
japón debe seguir promoviendo la paz con
las actuales tensiones en el mundo tengo
miedo de lo que pueda pasar llamada que
se acerca a los 90 años es uno de los
últimos vínculos humanos entre el
bombardeo atómico y los más jóvenes
pasamos por muchas cosas durante la
guerra ver a los niños sonreír es algo
precioso tenemos que protegerlos